I want to begin by thanking the
organizers of the conference both for 12
I mean also for thinking about this
event this year communities are now
giving you know if I think us to go back
once again meet and seat and think
seriously about Emily's legacy there
have been a number of commemorations
this year this may be the closest to the
way of the his death which was December
6th the commemoration that is going to
there may be more but there is going to
be one in a zillion itself next week on
that date that is coming in a few days
right now there is an international
philosophy forum even a sweater that is
served by the Ministry of Culture of the
Venezuelan government and this year it
was dedicated to France phenomena so
today we talk about the North African
springing and of course there are so
many ways in which panels relevant
understand today's political processes
and social movements in the region but I
think it's also good to insist that at
the same time his work left a number of
unfinished tasks that even we have that
spring there was enough of a knot of
reasons for us to meet and think about
him and his legacy in the way I want to
talk to you today about phenomena and as
a thinker of decolonization as an
a product it was thought it was said
this morning that maybe anti-colonialist
may be true that the colonization begins
with under colonialism but it certainly
but if certain is not true if the
decolonization finishes with just
independence there's formal political
independence is not by any means the
achievement of anything like the
decolonization even if it's actually
achieved which of course we even
questioned extent to which independence
were really given achieve the
colonization I think that we can be seen
as a task and indeed as a fundamentally
incomplete project that demands care and
attention and I think that in a way I
would have to have a difference with the
speaker in the previous panel existed of
the same type of socialism not that
socialism is not important but if I were
to have select one fundamental that they
were in phenomena like the first one
comes much money to characterize this
work and not only oppression of the
earth but from asking why mass it would
be something like relaxation I think I
mean I think conveniently from says
there's discourse on colonialism which
is about colonization and decolonization
and actually in fact best in my mask
begin with a paragraph from systems of
this course on colonialism
so I think that the clues to the frame
would have to write it there and
anything like the socialist politics I
think it's part of ezo decolonization
but also another part is central parts
of
or the issue of the elimination we have
sanitation gave us annexation of the
self-made oxidization of society and
common in the structure that were
naturalized in the Texas racial program
modernity legged that's why I think it's
interesting that he begins in that time
with epigraph from Sarah I'm not let's
say an area from and it's interesting
because when in places that for
socialism main framework you see and we
just saw these two days ago the
president of Bolivia who is himself
volatilization socialist his he is the
vice president of passing over Alex
which are indigenous indigenous Bolivia
but why now exterior the two other Excel
data is a very traditional socialist and
so we heard him opening this conference
and everything was about going back to
learning here the recept
date okay the greeting that he sent to
Chavez from he's an oxidizing precedent
to the all these mosques and I tell my
my brother that he was a Bolshevik
willing to fight for accounts so you
imagine and he still is is that one
thing that is not that that is not good
we are renouncing certain moments and
developments but I think that Furman was
thinking with another set of you would
have because you body because
coordinates and so to understand those
we have to look at this entire work and
other liberation of the earth and ask to
the world of course is here and other
figures that facility and in fact I
think that we can we can post phenomena
second essential thing clear of deep
relaxation as I don't finished early and
when I say like this I say in in
dialogue with Julian paradoxes effort to
do some modernity as I'm finished
product which I think that phenomena
have a different idea about the main
kind of project that doesn't mean that
modernity doesn't have anything at all
to offer to that project thought that
again they given a framework and the
horizon is a differently in different
place and I think must achieve other
things there are not only modernization
and even quality and annuity there are
other project and when you have you open
it when you think directly as the
finished project as the task in front of
us
you really are referred to well they
look in the document you are referred to
that the French Revolution to Europe as
the home
when that concept of constitutional
validity was sort of cooked
interestingly enough when at the end of
the depression of the earth fella says
let's leave this Europe alone I think
that in part you dismiss very Europe
that has been trying to refrain in this
other effort and in a way we found on
the other points that he puts on the
table for us is well the destruction of
Europe the language would be the Second
World War and the first world war an
important reference point
another one we the wave of
decolonization in the 20th century also
to some extent adhesion of evolution
although he was clear that he was he
didn't want to be taking just as a
person who is supposed to be interested
about the nation of evolution and
nothing more even wants to be reduced to
only be interested to that or to the
history of the slavery but that doesn't
mean that we didn't think that both is
really an occasion of evolution or
particularly important and of course
they lived experience as the man's
victory of he puts it in chapter 5
forecast in one mass of pressurized
subjects and subjects that are sort of
dehumanized and that demonization is
conceived in a way as not allowed or as
fix as possible and of course the
colonial world another litter box the
colonial world that is built in
relationship of police and police itself
independent of the current world so I
think that the main news the main
keywords the main columns of thinking
about the colonization as a huge project
the main sponsor references are these
and you can actually see them in his
work in a very clear way one could go
further and see if are known as engaging
in a political conversation with figures
such as the guard who saw been in the
country so many figures of faith
philosophy and they in a way seen he
must providing different answers to some
of the questions that in a way they
chair and they are questions not only
about political strategy or our economy
which is a tendency when we look at
finance work and work at that is read as
a as a sociology and of course there
were several it had elements but what
not only he wasn't only strictly
speaking and socially it was actually
sort of philosophical sociology and even
gauge many questions that have to do
with ontology philosophical anthropology
every stem ology methods common examples
are in a way you can even read thank you
know ways to serve for money sort of be
neglected that probably with this for
some colonialism which you cannot really
wheat in conversation with many regards
this course of methods you can see this
course on colonialism this was a method
for another page for another product for
the age of secularism not for the age of
science necessarily is not that science
of course I am
celery's but the ground that is trying
to prepare is the ground of a
decolonized humanity of the facilitation
and you require quite a bit of other
tools in order to ground our
understanding of reality such that the
polarization is possible is that how
they would have to be in order for the
polarization to be possible if it is
possible at all what cannot subject
those in need what kind of methods if at
all are necessary in order for us to
invade the past from colonial Italy to
the colorization those are some of the
fundamental questions that he's worked
that's 1007 the beginning they in a way
phones text his work is pregnant with
challenges that have been annexed
everything the process of being worked
out
so this interesting informative
questions i think that came naturally to
folks like this air can and finally part
because of the context the moment that
we were living in this is something that
a severe winter has very well he wasn't
with that country that context that
probably this sort of radical doubt
about the promises of the west and also
about the very even into some of the
capacities of the colonized subject
whose souls have been designed in a way
in functional economically itself that
doubt that we can so easily find that
tough deliberation that it is not that's
in the way is like is that you take the
right but wonder about how in how
incredible how you know the difficulty
of the condition and how difficult it is
indeed to try to find a way out that a
moment is the different moment that
ready to bob enforce the dis
consciousness
it was articulated in writing and
revisit the legacy and actually when you
those of you have double asking what
mass there are always a number students
who get deep into that roller coaster
and whose consciousness is people in
transformed so that I have to talk about
that text alongside all the tests which
are really powerful I think even more
take back with it with a modern
extendable damage and it tends to be in
a way blasting one pass that holds their
consciousness bring them into the text
and don't let them go on till the end of
their and America is completely
transformed traumatized right without
any effort without so to some extent
living in that context questions about
the mission of Revelation the course of
a policy of racism and also the
observation of the good consciousness
with which still when you know intellect
or sixteen regard colonialism as if we
are bringing civilization to them of
course that is what sets earth took a
map in this coastal ISM that again still
at that moment you know is coming down
in ashes conclusion and so do you think
like that but when you see is them still
defending the dignity of European
civilization just below Madison and then
you have that moment everyone jump out
of the table you know we really have to
rethink everything because we cannot
completely we cannot chops to the same
foundation so that that was trust and I
think that in a way if vertically you
can relate to sixteenth seventeenth
century or 12th to 16th century
the sciences being too much the church
the division descriptions begin to lose
value lose credibility and they've got
them only said well we can no longer so
much easily trust theology in the
scriptures but if not like we have
anything us or any foundation what are
we going to believe and that's where
figures like the card was done and other
figures begin to say well we have to
articulate the foundation for our new
set of beliefs for science but and then
they can't begin with the doubt whether
I got the best begin without in a way
this Caribbean subjects were introduced
to the house by the history any
historical circumstances or seen any
kind of Udo and seeing even when they
look around their own context this is
how I take to blasting my mask in a way
one of his many contributions to see
well that down in neurons that problem
is even a highly missile companies there
so it seems to pervade us and we do hit
that ground of complete uncertainty
either then you can begin again to try
to construct the basic pieces of what is
the self what in society that is what
why why at the end at the end of of
that's the one mass what does he want
this is not anything complicated is I
want to be you the world of the you
build the world of the you all of that
analysis all of that duration ends with
that proton affirmation which means you
have to figure out well what is the self
why do you and history including our
guests but at the end he he he interfere
with the foundations and at the end well
pray a prayer to be followed so even
even that is the reliance thinking the
body different something like the book
something like human consciousness
something like networking introduction
he says I live methods to the botanist
animal televisions beside phylogeny
Association so he was very clear this is
not just again it's also a legal
description because also previous on
methods treatise on fields of
anthropology in a very different way so
invite us to read with that complexity
on the other hand he was us versus her
and other figures reading French to
think this a philosophers the word
engaging Hegel and ontology and there
was Freud going around and so on so in a
way they would not but begin to think or
some information to those views and of
course they would notice rescue what
mast expects are pregnant with who knows
to these figures so it's clear that they
are in a critical conversation but you
see it's very different
particularly with Barack is not simply a
business here put it in popular terms
this is the figure that is hot this time
this is the figure that if I quote this
figure I will be able to be recognized
as an intellect or with others so let me
take that figure and let me write a
sequel to the colonial world you know he
does almost exactly the opposite he puts
them most of them just to their food
nose jobs to the funerals and then he
begins to have political conversation
with basically all of them all of them
I mean not like he doesn't is reacting
it in a small but
even with starch it takes some elements
and then he also criticizes evil he says
sir
he also will be sad when he begins with
this discourse on photorealism on the
beginning his criticizing magnitude
chapter 5
so you think si si is a very feeble mind
full with that intensity of critique but
in the service of not mourning the
destruction but he's trying to formulate
is that path of questioning but in a way
the card for in a hypothetical way but
here is the colonized subject to an
intense emotional process involved in
the in the analytic proposing that
process finding the basic elements that
would allow him to conceive but helps
the possibility of decolonization so in
this kind of project I think that is
extremely relevant and is if you've ever
done for a number of areas that are
given in a way you have begin with for
example us-africa and ethnics books
mentioning them here because I think
that well these fields emerge out of
activism which has a beginning in
comparison to many other fields with
video sections and I think when you ask
the folks who were push our founding
they were being funded they were
actively found so if you
that phenom is fenomena Caribbean
Martinique annejulien is power of the
main sources for something like us
ethnic studies and Africana Studies and
if so I will add upon us that maybe
these kind of crucial questions for the
let's put it like this which is
chromatic or maybe I'm running out of
time sorry needs more to the source of
these fields as Rousseau was to
anthropology ethnography that's in these
fields that emerge because of our
tradition it was not a big division
there wasn't much of intellectual drama
behind this which we also have to engage
seriously that that kind of philosophic
activity that ground of these areas in
context that I still see them absolutely
interdisciplinary collection of people
that come from different areas without
any substance on then also something
like even Caribbean studies and we are
working to Professor working program in
clinical Canadian Studies and the
Caribbean because of the classification
we have a a methodology as aware that
what we asked in the car again specific
Association I will finish with this one
one extend myself
that that that in a word part of the
questions for these areas this is blue I
think seminary Bellamy of the Civic
Association but I think is blue multi
badly or they took me to the Baltic
studies that the question is not so much
how how do you produce this to them with
a major 4x be prepared for X while you
see that the ultimate question is what
kind of conditions you create so that
they in the length of the subjectivities
that go through that program look more
like intellectually someone like Farnum
someone like the boys soul on axis here
then technocrats who knows a little bit
of diversity a nice inheritance by one
is how do you create the condition how
do you do it how do you do it
I mean so we might in the major what
kind of media would it be through the
process of being forum and coming to do
something like fine it's a different
thing that we are used to think when we
think about designing the major
everything like that in the Korean
Association will dominate conference
itself by actavis inviting artists and
inviting intellicus from many different
departments and areas and any questions
of concern at the center and some not so
much
and then finally we have us ethnic
studies in studies Caribbean philosophy
but also I think that fan on is very
important for something like critical
Latin American Studies phenomena spread
in Latin America with the translation of
those condenado de theater was in 1963
before the one in the United States for
reading in Latin America but it was
mainly folks you must read as an african
continent a thinker you know in another
continent that revolution fun on the
multimedia the black the black dick
director from the Americas was not so
much recognized and he was very
primarily by white light skinned
mestizos who were revolutionaries who
were thinking about Eurasian now for now
he's coming back to live in America but
this is maybe the best representations
that give you a sense this is an
indigenous publication this is sort of
allocation of the burden on the u.s.
into cultural studies at the University
of Mexico and you see that and then you
cannot see here I will stipulate it but
you see further space over South America
I've got money on the side
by from Singur cecilia winter Cavanaugh
who is cordon so at least some
indigenous
again providing a business oriented
Zapatista oriented publication so you
think this is not a variation of Latin
American story from the US and is not
even
the American story from from the south
either this is coming from the
revolutionary corners of the south and
Farnam is coming out with force as both
of Julian and as Martinique on and has
righted of depression of the earth
brass skin and so many other texts I
think for me they appreciate the value
of decolonization and conceiving it as
incomplete thank you